Oh!
Wait, you're not...
Wait, Sunny's live, right?
Okay, I'm live.
I'm live now.
I'm live.
Okay.
Just so you know, I'm also live now.
Damn, I can't tell you guys about my address and where I live anymore.
That's not...
Oh yeah, don't worry.
I can still say it out loud.
Don't worry, I'll just repeat it so everybody knows for sure.
So it was like...
Can you remind me Are you guys talking?
You guys are talking and I can't hear nobody.
Oh yeah, they're talking in game.
Damn it.
I'm putting it up as fast as I can.
Any settings that you would recommend or anything in this game?
No.
Tell her to get in the lobby and we'll tell her.
Yuki says to get in the fucking lobby and we'll tell her.
I'm calling it true, true.
See you later.
Okay, see you, see you.
Alright, we're just waiting for Snow.
Snuffy.
Weeeeee.
I love how...
I love how we were like nobody's live and then Snuffy came in and was like oh shit and then left.
She just immediately assumed the absolute worst.
She was like oh no they must be discussing trade secrets.
Oh no.
The NDA leaks.
No.
Alright, we're just waiting for Snow.
I'm just waiting for Snuffy.
I'm gonna be a part of for the next six years.
Oh no.
You're gonna break your contract.
NDA.
All for content warning.
All for the content.
Anything for content.
If this video hits a hundred thousand likes I'm gonna leak everything.
Real.
I'll leak everything for a hundred thousand likes.
Not even for money.
I'll do it for likes only.
That's how much I love con...
That's fucking right and I'll do it again.
Wonderful.
It's all about the algorithm baby.
Remember hit that like button.
Subscribe.
Hit that notification bell.
And also comment on my channel to boost up the algorithm.
Follow my Twitter.
Yeah, follow my Twitter.
Follow me on Twitter.
Follow me on Twitch.
Follow me on YouTube.
And also follow...
You can't skip this ad.
And also use my gamer subs code.
DokiBird.
Get access to my private Snapchat.
Oh shit.
Oh you're that type of content creator.
No I'm really not.
It's okay Lime.
Own it Lime.
Don't be ashamed.
No judgment here.
I would never judge you Lime.
Guys if you tier 3 sub to Lime right now.
You'll get access to her...
You'll get access to her secret Snapchat.
Tier 3?
I'm so fucking low.
I subbed.
You gotta make sure you turn the audio to like really low.
Because this game's audio is fucking terrible.
It's a funny...
I just like to watch.
I think I just like...
I think I just like maxed it on my stream.
Oh you maxed it?
Bro you're fucking crazy.
Like what you hear in this room is not as bad as...
Hello chat.
Hello.
Can you hear us?
Nothing.
Is this loud enough?
Han is just standing there like...
Hey.
Somehow he's the loudest.
Oh my god.
He didn't even say anything.
You can actually turn us up and down individually if you hit escape top right.
I had to turn push to talk on because my dog is playing with a squeaky toy.
I'm just gonna test.
You can't hear me.
Nothing bad will happen.
I was just wondering how the fuck are you the loudest Han?
You literally barely said anything.
You got the HD though.
Oh yeah true.
You can hear his voice even smoother.
I need the DLC to get HD.
Yeah.
Holy shit you are loud.
What the fuck?
Hello.
Wait how do you guys get funny... oh.
Yeah you can change your face.
You can draw a penis.
What's that?
You can rotate it as well.
What the fuck is that?
I think I fucked it up.
How do I get rid of this?
There you go.
You have deleted your face.
You just have to clear it up.
Oh what are you trying to do?
Oh are those balls?
Oh okay.
I was like what the fuck?
Do you see the balls?
Like what the fuck are you doing?
It's Peter Griffin.
Guys this is like Christian...
Oh yeah it does look like Peter Griffin.
The ball chin.
This one is kind of swag actually.
I dig that.
What color are you guys?
I want to be blue.
I'm red.
I have no idea what color I am.
I think I should be blue.
Yellow.
Wait let me look at your faces.
Let me take a quick look for reference.
Alright.
That's me.
You got a bunch of tits.
You're just very happy.
Very content.
And you're quite the opposite.
Alright some good faces.
Wait Han.
Han you're fucking icon Sonic?
Stop.
I was like what the fuck is this guy on my screen?
Oh my god it is.
It's like Sonic 1 Sonic.
Yeah the OG Sonic.
I love the wagging finger Sonic.
That's like the most iconic.
You're gonna change it Steve?
Oh the guys here?
Keanu Reeves is gonna be Shadow.
I'm so excited.
I am so excited for it.
It's gonna be amazing.
Oh my god for the casting for them.
I feel like all the budgets went to casting for that movie.
Is Sonic even like somebody cool?
Yeah.
He's just like a guy right?
No he's not just a guy.
He was in like...
He was in DuckTales.
For real?
Yeah.
He was one of...
He was like Louie Dewey and the other guy.
I don't remember who he was.
No fucking way he was Huey bro.
That's my favorite one.
I can't believe you just called him some guy.
I know but he was actually Huey the duck.
He was Dewey.
That's almost as big as Sonic.
I know he was just as famous.
But there was like what Idris Elba.
I think Sonic is cool.
As Knuckles and then...
Oh yeah Idris Elba is cool.
Okay so I think...
That's the guy with the list.
Snuffy is like the only one who hasn't played content warning yet.
I am...
She's like the intern that we hired for our YouTube channel.
So we sent her first right?
Yeah we sent her first.
Wait we should let Snuffy hold the camera then.
Like let her...
experience recording for the channel.
Oh god yeah okay.
I just got hired as an editor.
Oh my god you just...
Oh my god and she's doing it for the experience.
Oh my god yes!
One of the biggest YouTubers ever.
I can't wait to do it for the...
exposure.
The exposure you can put that on your resume.
You don't need to get paid you just need views.
Okay so how do I do this?
What do I do?
Okay so who wants to explain to...
Snuffy the instructions on being...
cameraman?
You gotta point it at stuff...
and capture scary things.
And also you have a limited amount of tape.
So good luck.
Does it show you?
Yeah it shows you on your top right.
You can also change it to selfie mode.
If you want to.
I have an apple.
Oh cute.
You can get the apple.
Oh my god.
How did you get the apple?
Howdy folks.
How did you do that?
Oh my god there's apples.
Very good.
Okay.
Also...
Snuffy just so you know.
My game tends to bug out and every time I come back from a mission...
I lose all microphone audio.
So if I stop talking to you it's not because I hate you.
It's just because...
Okay if I stop talking to you it's because I hate you.
Why is that?
Yeah.
Film us with the apple.
That's content.
Snuffy.
I don't have an apple.
I didn't touch apples.
Film us.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Can you drop it like those Burger King commercials?
Oh my god.
What was it called?
Like those thirst traps of an apple?
You're gonna make a thirst trap of an apple.
For the content.
I just wasted so much footage on these apples.
Okay okay let's go fucking...
How much do we have left?
Okay we gotta go.
75.
Nice fantastic let's go.
Let's go.
I like how we didn't...
We don't need any... we don't need introduction.
We all know who's who.
Oh yeah true.
I can't even see your name.
I'll just...
We'll call you by your... your... your...
Your color.
Avery red.
Happy happy yellow and upset green.
Yellow where are you?
Yellow!
Okay this is where you truly test the audio Snuffy.
Okay this is actually much scarier.
Do you still have the camera Snuffy?
Snuffy?
She dropped...
She dropped the camera.
Oh.
It's okay I trust in Han.
Han I know you're so good at making content.
I got it stuck in my pocket.
I'm gonna go die.
Yeah go die for content Han.
We have to go viral.
For content.
Okay but you need to die while the camera's rolling.
You can't die without the camera.
That's the point.
Your life will be worthless.
You would've seen it so that would've been fine.
Yeah but...
Yeah but my eyes don't have film.
Your life is only worth something if it's filmed.
Okay okay record him jumping down Snuffy.
Record you?
You want the camera on you right now?
Yeah yeah yeah.
Welcome to Ghostbusters.
Hey what?
What?
I thought you said Mythbusters.
I was like oh my god what myth are we busting today?
Okay Snuffy.
Just make sure you film all the content.
We gotta go viral.
I'm in the back here.
I've got the backpack on.
It's okay we all know.
We all know.
The person with the camera can never die.
I think we're gonna die.
No we're not we'll be fine.
We'll be fine.
What I've learned is that if you go down it'll eventually go up.
Oh shit look see.
I already got to the exit.
Look at that.
I found the exit.
What?
Please film us for the content.
Before we die.
Oh guys.
Okay I'm trying.
Film it film it film it.
You guys are slow as hell.
Film.
Did you get the spider?
It can't be that dangerous right?
Okay yeah it can't be that.
Oh my god.
He missed he missed.
We go this way we go this way.
It's okay he's not chasing us.
We're okay.
We're so fine.
It's alright.
The beginning level is never that bad.
There's only like one really scary monster.
And everything else is fine.
Oh look at you min maxing everything.
Yeah that's right.
That's why I'm a gamer.
Try hard.
Look you gotta try hard.
And you wanna go viral.
It's all about studying the algorithm.
Oh my god what hit me?
What hit me?
What did I got hit by?
I'm so scared.
Where the fuck are the others?
But.
Whatever happens to me.
Yeah?
I'm gonna go to the ground and meet...
Hello?
Oh you're okay you're okay.
What's up?
Oh I might be okay.
Okay.
I'd only be bad if I did this.
Do you think he's okay?
You're in zone!
Are you still okay?
You're still okay!
You did it!
Yay!
We're fine we're fine.
My flashlight's on.
It's okay I have 20%.
What we learned is that you're indestructible.
Just like that M.
Night Shyamalama movie.
You're right I should test it out.
Wait wait wait wait.
Maybe not again.
Maybe I should test it out.
Maybe I'm invisible just like you.
I don't trust you.
What do you mean you don't trust me?
I have the flashlight.
Watch this.
Okay.
Okay movie.
You wish.
It's gone.
Are you dead?
Oh hey!
I had to stop.
I had to take it from Milo.
She said she had arachnophobia so I was just like.
Jamie.
Oh my god.
I...
Han and I were testing out a theory.
And like.
Oh yeah?
I was wrong in my theory.
What was the theory?
Well.
We're testing out.
We're both invincible.
And like.
Well as you found out.
One of us wasn't.
What kind of fucking roids are you guys sniffing?
And you just loaded the whole world.
And you're like.
I think it might be fucking invincible.
Look it was like Mythbusters.
You know?
Like.
We got to bust that myth.
But if he's.
Am I fucking God right now?
Are we busted?
Oh but I'm running.
I just wanted to know.
And we just.
Look he survived.
Look Han survived.
How I suppose to know.
I wouldn't survive.
How do I switch?
Can you like switch who you're spectating?
Yeah.
You can't.
W-A-W-A-D.
Oh...
You must be invincible!
See?
Like, okay!
I was...
I half busted the myth.
One of us wasn't invincible.
How was I supposed to know I wasn't the main character?
Everyone thinks they're the main character of the story.
That might be the most horrific realization.
Is that you're not the main character.
Not even on my own stream.
I'm not the main character.
It's so fucked up.
I am so happy for you.
Aw, thank you.
I can't believe it.
That means either of us were not the main character, Snuffy.
We're NPCs.
Hell yeah.
We're fucking NPCs.
We're like the cool characters.
Show up for like one episode...
Yeah, and then everybody loves us.
Even though we showed up for one episode.
Yeah.
But everybody loves us.
Wait, where are we?
We have to go here.
We have to go back to the main lobby.
Guys.
I was...
Han and I were trying to do a myth buster thing and we busted a myth.
I was not invincible.
Snuffy, did you call the spider a dumb bitch as you died?
Yes, she did.
We might have used some language.
We might have to cut that for YouTube.
I'm so excited to see our first video.
This is my first ever content.
Oh my god, your first ever YouTube upload.
You get to hear how fucking awful the audio is once it actually gets uploaded.
It's great.
Oh my god.
Our first video.
Guys, we gotta get monetized.
The first video?
You're dreaming.
Guys, we gotta get 3,000 watch hours so we can get monetized.
Don't forget to put a bunch of red circles on the thumbnail.
I'll be on my TV all day.
Howdy folks.
First day on the job.
Let's see how it goes.
Can you drop it in the Everking commercials where they drop food in really HD splashes?
What was it called?
Like those like thirst traps?
Why is this 50% of the video?
How do you make a thirst trap?
Yeah, you left me so little video to actually film the spider.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god, Snuffy.
I found a spy.
Knee destruction tutorial by Snuffy.
Get
out of my way.
Get out of my way?
You awful...
Alright chat.
Today we're about to find out if this spider web is sticky.
All my friends went missing.
Now let's see if this bitch sticks.
This is pretty sticky.
What the fuck?
I don't think I can move...
I don't think I can move my limbs.
Am I moving?
Am I breaking free?
This is so embarrassing.
I liked it.
That's the last shot of mine.
That was really good.
What a story.
How many views did we get?
Oh we are 1.5.
We're halfway there.
Yeah, we're halfway there one day.
Look at that.
We're gonna get monetized soon guys.
That's freaking good.
That's so good.
1k?
I don't even know that many people.
Oh my god.
I can't believe that's our debut stream.
1.5k.
Dang.
Oh my god.
We got to title it something good like entangled by sticky web.
Oh no.
We're like what is this?
It's a sticky mess and then we're gonna make clickbait thumbnail where Snuffy is covered in white sticky web.
Oh god.
It's not even subtle.
Wait where's the camera?
How do we get there?
Where's the camera?
Wait where the fuck did the camera go?
Wait.
Gotta get asleep.
Oh yeah.
I forgot.
This is unrealistic because it implies content creator sleep.
Yeah let's go.
It will not let me sleep.
Okay there we go.
Alright.
Are we gonna wake.
When are we gonna wake up?
Oh shit sleep streams.
Always gives us views.
Yeah.
Oh boy I can't wait to make content.
Oh my god.
Yippee.
Another great day to make content.
We need to risk our last reviews.
Alright, who wants to do the camera next?
Yeah, now that we have $200...
We should get the...
Wait.
Oh, we...
We gotta get the heal item.
I'm gonna order the heal item.
I'm gonna order the hug.
Does anybody wanna...
Do we get unlimited hugs?
We just can't die.
Also, we might need two more flashlights.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, hey, there's the camera!
I'll grab this flashlight.
Don't worry, I'm gonna charge it.
Oh, it's charged.
So basically, I have a thing...
Snuffy, where...
I hug you and then you're gonna be full HP.
That would be like...
Hug.
Do you have to hold this?
I have to hold to hug you.
And then if you have 0 HP...
Just ask for hugs and I'll be like...
Oh my God!
What the...
What do you get?
We had 100,000...
It's really useful, see?
What is that gonna do?
Worth it, worth it, worth it.
What is that gonna do for us?
It's gonna give me so many views.
The peace side we come in, please.
I'm gonna go viral with this shit, don't worry.
You're gonna go viral with the peace side.
Look, look, look, look, Snuffy.
That's good, that's really good.
Alright, let's go.
Content time.
I'm gonna get like a signature too.
We all have to have like a fun quirk.
A fun quirk?
I'm a Homestuck troll.
We're such a quirky squad.
We're gonna be like the Logang.
What's that?
The Logang?
You know, like that...
That gang from Logang... was it Logan Paul?
He had like a whole gang and stuff.
Oh, the Logang?
What's that Logang?
What was it called?
Team 10?
We're gonna be Team 10!
What's Logan Paul's Oshimark?
What's Logan Paul?
Is it like a Maverick or whatever?
Like some fucking bird?
I don't know why I know so much about that.
What?
I feel like Laura has never even heard.
Yeah, that's not what he called his fans!
The Mavericks or whatever the fuck.
The Mavericks?
Because it was like based off of like his fucking bird.
I don't even know if he has a bird.
I think that's a helicopter.
A Maverick?
Nice.
Woo!
Holy shit!
That's alright.
Just a scratch.
My god.
It is seeing the fucking flop.
Who's the leader?
Who's the team leader?
I think the person with the peace sign.
Oh, you're true.
That's me.
She has the most money apparently.
Sacrifice for the content.
Don't you wanna be just like your Oshi Logan Paul?
Don't
you wanna be just like your Oshi Logan Paul?
Don't let him touch you!
He got... she got touched!
Where the fuck did he come from?
I think she went this way.
What was that?
Did Hana get like abducted?
Yeah, Hana got abducted!
That's a camera!
She got touched!
That's the camera!
Wait, no, but you don't insta-die though.
You just get kidnapped, abducted.
We gotta put him on milk cartons soon.
Oh, I gotta go find him?
Oh, there he is!
What's your HP?
Do you need hugs?
Wonderful time, thank you.
Here you go.
Are you fully healed?
You need a friendship hug?
Yeah, thank you!
There you go.
I got traumatized.
Don't worry, the easiest fix for trauma.
He's coming back!
Oh my god!
I just see it like...
Wait, does he still have my camera?
No, no, it's okay.
Okay, thank god.
Nothing was lost then.
I only have 31% battery.
Hon!
I think he went up here.
Hon, where are you?
I hear some googly noises, so maybe it's over here?
Did you hear that?
Woo!
Guys!
I'm scared!
I'm gonna get abducted!
No!
Oh no, let me go!
Let me go!
Please!
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay.
I see their faces.
I see it.
It was a setup.
I see their faces.
Ah!
Guys!
Oh, god.
Oh, I hear you guys!
I'm at the spaceship!
I'm at the safe...
Oh, wait, I got taxied back to my spaceship.
So convenient.
That's so convenient, guys.
I'm just gonna go back to the ship real fast.
I don't feel safe outside anymore.
I don't feel safe outside.
For content.
Alright.
Just gotta make sure.
Are they alive?
Is Han alive?
Oh, Han's alive.
Okay.
Guys!
Woo!
Fill me!
There's a ghost!
Oh my god!
It's not the E-1 Recon!
Please!
Oh, god.
Someone hug me!
Someone hug me right now!
Oh my god, hug me!
Oh, thank you!
Do you feel better?
Can I get more hugs?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need more.
My trauma is alive.
I have a lot of trauma.
Alright.
We're good.
Yeah, yeah, I can hug.
Do you need hugs too, Han?
Are you traumatized?
Nah, there's no way I need hugs.
Alright.
Guys, I think Han died.
Wait!
Hey, can you hug him back to life?
Guys, he's a strong man.
He's hugging a corpse.
I don't think I can hug him back.
Okay, I ran out of battery.
Let's wrap this bitch right here.
Wait, wait, did you film the dead body?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, thank god.
At least he didn't die for nothing.
Guys, I had a feeling that maybe Han needed that hug.
Just a maybe.
He died for ads, Reverend.
That's true.
For the ads.
Guys, I think we're gonna get 3000 watch hours.
This one's good.
I think it's really good.
This one has got real good potential.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Han was like Vincent Van Gogh.
After he dies, he becomes famous.
Oh, true.
Here's your flashlight.
I'm gonna hospital bill only $3.
So unrealistic.
I was gonna say it's kinda cheap.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Let me charge up my flashlight.
Han, I think you needed that hug, Han.
Just a maybe.
And then it will give you a CD.
These are pretty retro.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
This is old world technology.
Oh my god.
We're so retro.
I heard CDs can now hold a terabyte of space.
A terabyte?
Is that a lot?
Yeah.
I have to hold the hug you and then...
No, you skipped the best part!
Nice.
Woo!
Oh, what the...
I'm gonna get it!
Dude, help!
I'm running for my life.
Yo, it's hot!
My love!
I'm getting hit by the fucking thing!
Oh god!
What keeps happening?
Is this how you lead him away?
Oh yeah, do you wanna check the ship?
Look at you go!
This is really uncomfortable walk cycle.
What's that fucking chat comment?
I didn't know three.
Three's are alive?
Question mark?
Yo, yo, snail guy, snail guy, where did you get your outfit?
Where did you get your outfit?
I got it from Spencer's.
What?
Do you want your hug?
No, you died!
You died!
What the fuck are you filming here?
Oh, there he is.
There's a little snot creature.
What a handsome lad.
Oh my god, I think we did it!
We made the quota!
Hell yeah, we made it easy.
We did it and we can stack the next CD.
The ad revenue was huge!
I know!
Oh my god!
Guys, I think we can...
I think we're close to taking a Raid Shadow Legends sponsor.
I think we're gonna be in an overnight sensation.
Oh my god, they pay so well.
Like 500,000 Ys.
Oh my god.
We're gonna be so famous that Raid Shadow Legends is gonna notice us.
Raid Shadow Legends!
Brought to you by Raid Shadow Legends.
Sponsored by a meal kit plan.
Or like ExpressVPN.
.
Okay.
I gotta charge my flashlight.
What?
Flashlight fully charged.
Can we afford anything?
Anybody want a videotape?
Okay, who hasn't... Okay, I'll videotape.
Don't worry guys.
I'm a great character.
I'm a great camera person.
I think you should learn how to backflip, Snuffy.
Backflip?
Do we have enough for it?
I see yoga.
How do you backflip?
It's in the second... It's in the first one.
It's $300.
We don't have enough money.
Caring looks more like Confine.
What is Thumbnail 1?
That's very intriguing.
Is he like reverse planking?
There's gymnastics.
We don't have enough money for a backflip.
You have to save up.
What about Sound Player?
It sounds like it would be good.
You can add a laugh track.
You're cooler than me.
I get it.
Guys, we can make the next Big Bang Theory.
Bazinga.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, every time.
Just put a laugh track so people know it's funny.
Oh my god, nice zoom.
This is going to be great.
Breaking news.
Are we ready for more content?
Let's go.
There's so many sound effects that you can make.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
I think we can get to a million views, guys.
I think it's possible.
One million?
Yeah!
We're going to get one million play button.
Oh yeah, because I'm not getting like really meta sounds.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You gotta be like super meta.
Like game show intro.
Did no one press the button?
I think none of us pressed the button.
We were just like having a little conversation.
Hello and welcome back to our channel.
Today, this is day 25 of...
This is just...
Day 25 exploring the caverns.
Alright, here we go.
Wait, where is the cavern?
Where are we?
Where the fuck?
Oh shit, what?
Alright,
you gotta put a sound effect while we fall down.
Woooo!
Oh, my god!
I'm okay.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Where should we go?
What kind of story are we trying to tell with this next video?
Yeah, yeah.
What's their story?
We gotta...
We gotta make it scripted, guys.
We all know the best content is scripted.
Oh, oh, that's...
That's just Lime over there.
I thought that was a monster.
Okay, so we gotta pay for an actor.
To scare us.
And then make it seem natural.
Oh, no!
Oh, my god!
You guys wouldn't believe what I just saw!
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I got you.
Boom.
We gotta...
Throw this at her!
Okay, wait, wait.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I learned this...
I learned this from a friend.
Wait, where did my camera...
Just fall down.
I cannot fall down.
Wait, I can't...
You gotta hit me.
We gotta throw something and hit her.
Wait, somebody like climb on my head or something.
Somebody climb on her head.
I'm going to die.
I'll miss you guys.
I can't hit her!
No!
Did I hit her?
Oh, she did.
She's still hanging in there.
Oh, no.
Okay, someone's trying to flash light on her.
Okay.
So fucking stupid.
Oh, yeah, dude.
Wait, wait, put a lap track on there again.
Put a lap track.
Okay, nice.
Where the fuck did I put my flashlight?
I threw my flashlight on the floor.
Did you guys take it?
Oh, I took it.
Okay, okay.
Alright,
nice.
Okay, one of you guys should have the flashlight.
Because I have the camera out.
I got the sound effects.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Han's our flashlight person.
I'm the flashlight person.
Alright, lead us, Han.
I just realized that maybe we're not good at throwing flashlights.
I'm gonna try to do some things.
Because all three of us unsuccessfully hit the target.
Who's that?
Where is he?
Whoa, what the fuck is that?
What the fuck is that?
Oh my god, if only you guys could see what I'm looking at right now.
Oh my god.
Oh, shit.
Okay, he doesn't like that.
Why me?
I'm the cameraman.
Oh my god.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, things are happening right now.
Oh my god.
She's dead.
Wait, she's dead?
Okay, Han, I think we got...
Han, Han, hug me.
Hug me, I have trauma.
Han, you need to hug me.
I have trauma.
Yay.
It'll be all better.
Can I trauma dump on you?
Hahaha.
And that's all, folks.
Alright, do you need hugs too?
Alright, nice.
Alright.
I still... I think we got...
Do you think we're gonna survive?
Because I still have 49% of my footage.
Do we know how to go back though?
I already got lost.
Ah, we can survive.
Let's go.
Alright, alright.
I believe in you.
I believe...
What's that?
Oh, is that this guy again?
AHHHHHH!
Go back, go back, go back, go back!
Why did you split up, Han?
Oh no.
Down is up, down is up, down is up, guys.
Down is up.
Okay.
Oh shit, look at the sick bone.
Right here.
Guys, look.
I found a bone.
Right here.
Can you guys see it?
Okay, wait.
Wait.
Look at the sick bone.
Right here.
Okay.
I think you guys saw it.
Down is up.
Just gotta go...
OH!
DOWN IS UP!
I did it!
Yay!
I knew I can find my way home.
Spaceship though.
Alright.
But where is...
Oh no.
No flashlight.
Oh!
Where the fuck is that spaceship?
Where is the spaceship?
Where is the spaceship though?
That is...
a little concerning.
Hello?
I think I hear sound effects.
From Han.
Oh, what the...
It saw me.
It saw me!
No!
The camera!
Oh!
Oh my god!
It's the camera!
The camera!
I can't believe!
Oh!
No!
We all died!
Her ass was too big a snack.
Oh shit!
We had you die, Han!
We had you...
We had you die!
That was great.
Good job everybody.
My content!
Where is my freaking content?
We gotta find the camera!
You can actually go back and get the camera.
We have to get the camera.
What the fuck did you die, Han?
Oh god!
Oh, what?
I got stabbed by that guy.
That pupil guy.
Oh shit!
No, we lost our hugs.
I can't believe.
I can't believe I couldn't find the spaceship.
It's okay.
I still have the peace sign.
It's alright guys.
We didn't lose everything.
You guys lay down on the beds like you're making snow angels.
Oh my god.
At least we made Koda.
We did it!
Do we need another camera to take to find the camera?
Yeah, they gave us two cameras so we can like find the camera and then like make more content.
And wake up.
We got a lot of money for jumpscares.
Lime.
Lime, you gotta wake up.
Yeah, wake up.
You gotta wake up, Lime.
I've been doing content for like 8 hours already.
Okay, we gotta buy the hug again.
We gotta get the hug.
Nice.
Alright.
That's all our money.
I can't believe they monetized hugs.
Is the soundboard gonna still be there too?
No.
We gotta save up for the soundboard again.
What did you buy?
What's that?
Party popper?
Oh my god, the party popper!
Alright, we use it for like very important situations cause it's one use only.
Like when you use it over someone's body.
Yeah, yeah.
So like when somebody dies, you pop the party popper.
Oh, we don't have flashlights, guys.
I just realized we spend money on party poppers and not flashlights.
Oh.
Maybe the explosion will like light us on a brief.
That's okay, we don't need to fucking see it.
Yeah, we don't need to see it.
Our camera can see for us.
I've got like, I've got magnets in my head.
You got the 5 G's in your head?
The fuck do you mean you have magnets in your head?
What the fuck does that mean?
I need other things.
Oh my god, she's got the 5 G's.
It's okay guys, I've got magnets in my head.
Oh, okay.
Guys, we gotta find the camera first.
No, it's a different map.
We can't find anything anymore.
Oh wait, it's the second map.
Wait, we cannot find it even if it's like...
Would it be...
If we get that same map again, will we be able to find it?
I don't know.
The first three?
Oh, okay.
So we still have the second map.
The second day.
To find it.
Oh, this is a little spooky.
Guys, I wish we had something that can let us see the world better.
Oh, it's this tabby dude again.
Oh, it's him!
He's so lit.
Hold on, let me flash a peace sign with this.
He doesn't know yet.
Yeah.
We're like tourists.
You know like those like...
Those guys that wear those long hats in the queen's palace?
Sorry, the king's palace.
Oh!
He's asleep.
Who woke him up?
Oh no.
Am I okay?
I'm fine.
Okay, okay.
Here.
Okay.
Hug.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
Oh, don't go!
No, you fell!
Oh!
Todd, you need to come down here for hugs!
Long live the king.
Oh no!
I swear, I hope somebody stabs you.
Oh shit!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hey Ricky, how's it going?
I need hugs, I need hugs.
Here, here, here.
Did you grab it?
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
We gotta go around.
Oh shit, okay.
Oh, you didn't get me, you didn't grab it.
Oh, hon, no!
Hon, drop the hugs!
This way, this way, this way.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Give me the thing.
No!
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
Just keep hugging me through the pain.
Hug me!
No!
Hon,
you gotta drop the thing so I can hug you too!
I dropped it, I dropped it.
Where did you drop it?
I dropped it back there.
Okay.
Point it to me, point it to me.
Oh no.
Oh, where did you drop it?
We don't have the thing that can let us see the ground!
Oh no.
I got it, I got it, I got it!
Drop it, Junkie, drop it next to me.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Hon, you're live!
Okay.
Keep going, keep going.
Gotta get out of here.
I don't like your chances.
Where did you go?
Where did you go, Hon?
I'm over here, I'm over here, I'm over here!
I'm lost!
I'm so lost!
Hon!
Follow my voice, follow my voice.
You follow my...
Hon, Hon, Hon, get over here, get over here!
Okay, okay.
Okay.
You gotta make sure.
Okay, okay, okay.
Your turn, your turn.
This is our only way to live.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
What's that?
I heard... Did you hear that?
Did you hear that?
That's the monster sound.
Hon, I don't think...
Hon, I think we should have...
Hon, I think we should have bought flashlights.
We should have bought flashlights.
Can we?
Don't worry!
Don't worry, it's just a snail!
It's just a snail!
You can't die from him!
Don't weep!
Oh, you should hear about that!
Okay, hug!
Drop the hug!
I'll hug you!
Okay.
I dropped the hug.
Okay, here you go.
It's luck.
Here you go.
Are you okay now?
Behind us, behind us, behind us.
Hon!
Wait, I hear them!
Guys!
We're lost!
Help us!
Help me!
Oh my god!
I'm okay, I'm okay!
I'm okay, I'm okay.
You're fine, you're fine.
I'm being attacked by a straw!
No, no, no, we're okay!
I dropped the hug, it's your turn.
He can't climb.
I have to go hug him.
Okay, he can't...
Is that you guys?
Hey, what's up?
We're gonna die.
We are stuck guys.
We're sort of stuck.
So if anything happens, remember us for the content.
I will.
I think you can get up.
No, we try.
We don't know where the exit is.
I'm scared.
Alright, okay, okay, hon.
Follow me.
Follow me, hon!
Okay, we go this way.
We go this way.
And then...
This way, this way, this way.
This way seems like the right way.
Right?
I'm not a stamina.
Oh, this seems like the right way.
Maybe...
Where is...
I can't see anything.
I don't know what's following us.
People.
People is following us.
Where are you?
What is this thing?
What is it?
I can't tell!
Are you okay?
I think you're okay.
I'm gonna go the other way.
Oh, I hear the bubble.
I hear the blob.
Hon, I hear the blob.
I can't see anything!
Follow my voice, hon!
Follow my voice!
I'm right behind you.
Okay, okay, okay.
There has to be a way out.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, no, that's just a...
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
I think we're gonna die from the lack of oxygen!
Jump on my head.
You can do it.
Okay.
Oh, no.
We're never getting out!
Wait!
Hon, did you...
Down is up!
Hon, I went down!
Oh, no.
Down is always up.
Oh, one of us will live.
One of us will live.
Please, God.
That's all that matters.
Oh, we're gonna die from the lack of oxygen!
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Down, down is up.
Down is up.
It's always worked.
Oh, my God, my philosophy has always been right.
Oh, my God, am I fucking gonna get out of here?
Oh, no.
I have so little oxygen right now.
This relies on time now.
Oh, no, I'm not gonna make it, guys.
Guys, I don't think I'm gonna make it.
There's so little oxygen.
Okay.
Oh!
I have so little oxygen!
Yeah, we're kinda running out.
Go to the ship!
Go to the ship line!
I figured it out!
Run to the ship!
I'm here!
Help me!
I'm sorry, Han.
We don't have time anymore.
Woo!
The door!
It's the door!
I'm gonna find you.
Oh, no!
No!
I was just there!
I thought you didn't have to go up the second flight of stairs.
You were stuck on the ground.
I saw the ship in front of me!
I literally saw the ship!
Oh, my God!
I was so close!
That guy killed me like 20 minutes ago!
Don't kill me!
Oh, food!
That was good footage!
Oh, my God!
I thought...
I can't believe it!
How did you die, Stuffy?
I got killed by the same thing that killed me!
Oh!
Han, how did you die, Han?
Snuffy, please!
Please stop!
Snuffy!
How did you die?
You died from the lack of air?
Alright, alright.
I'm trying to focus right now, but for some reason, my body is glitching and breathing in the loudest of my ears.
Oh, shit!
Do I still have to go to the hospital if I'm technically on the ship?
Yeah, you do, because you're fucking dead.
I'm dead.
I kept on getting kidnapped by a tardigrade.
It was weird.
Oh, my God.
I worked so hard, too!
I figured...
I got out of the maze!
I was floating up and down, right?
It was vibrating.
I got like a second of it before the camera ran out of range.
Oh, my God.
I actually figured out how to get back, and then I got fucking gunned down.
It was so...
How did you get back?
Down is up!
You go down and go up!
Was it...
Did you get stuck in that place where there's like just a...
like four corridors?
We could barely see what was going on.
We could barely see...
There was a hole in the floor underneath that stairs.
Yeah.
Yeah, I got chased by a spider back there once.
It was awful.
There were so many corridors.
We kept getting lost.
It's okay.
We got content, though.
It's very exciting footage.
It has to be very good content.
We use it for like very important situations.
Yo, is that Doki Bori?
Let us see the world.
Look at it again.
Oh, it's him!
Let me flash a peace sign with this.
He doesn't know yet.
Yeah.
Like those guys that were...
I think he's asleep.
Totally asleep.
He's coming.
Oh, my God.
We got 4.5k.
Fuck.
We got 4.5k views for that.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
The views are skyrocketing.
Bro, it's going up.
It's only our third...
fourth day as a content creator.
Not sure about the phones.
Hey, guys.
Hey, what's up?
I'm gonna throw this up to you.
Oh, snap.
If anything happens, remember us for the content.
I think you can get up.
We have to go around the world.
We tried.
I'm scared.
15k.
I think I'm gonna get attacked by bubbles.
16.
Hello?
Hey, you still having a good time down there?
Just joking, dad.
I like your dogs.
Oh, my God.
There's like three guys down there.
There's skedaddling.
No!
What the fuck was that?
I don't listen to you.
I don't listen to you at all.
Oh, shit.
The fucking vibrating body.
You were doing that for like the last minute, which is why I was just stood there staring at you.
Because it was fucking mesmerizing.
I couldn't hear anything because it was so loud.
Were you just listening to that?
Yeah.
It was like, chat was like, one moment he was there and then the next he was gone.
Like a magic trick.
Oh my god.
I hope we can find the camera in the next one.
I'm gonna go buy a... wait, you have the hug now, right Lime?
Uh, yeah, yeah, yeah, we don't need it.
Oh, okay, I'll hold it.
We might need a flashlight.
I'm gonna buy us...
We should get some flashlights though.
Should we get the long... should we invest on a long flashlight?
If we stick together, we only need like one good one.
Yeah, alright, I'll invest on the long flashlight.
Okay, who has died the least?
I think Lime has died the least out of all of us.
That's because I'm a coward.
I think you should hold the flashlight.
Sure.
That's like $200 worth of...
Oh my god.
Hey, it's not about... It's so big.
It's not about the size, it's how you use it.
It's about the ocean of the motion... It's about the motion of the ocean.
What?
Is that how it goes?
About flashlights?
I've never heard that in my life.
What is Snuffy getting?
Is she getting water or food?
Or bathroom?
She said beverage, so I'm assuming maybe water, but maybe alcohol.
Oh my god, what?
Maybe alcohol... She needs to cope right now.
Oh shit, wait, we should film this.
We should...
Who has the camera?
Like, knock you down?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Wrong person.
Down with Snuffy.
Oh my god, I can't even hit her.
Holy!
You took her out!
Oh my gosh.
I'm practicing right now.
I'm practicing my karate.
Watch this.
It's like Karate Kid.
You're joking from the top rope.
Alright, ready?
I'm gonna stand up here.
Do it.
Alright, 3, 2, 1.
Did I miss?
You kinda like, clipped the top of her head.
Okay, wait, wait.
I'm practicing.
I'm practicing for the real deal.
Oh!
I almost pinned her down!
You try.
Alright, alright.
Alright, let me...
Push her closer to the rock.
Oh, here you go.
Oh!
Oh my god!
It's like you're used to this.
You have...
Clearly have so much practice.
It's our synergy.
We just love knocking each other to the floor.
Oh, shit.
I'm like, sure.
What happened to the synergy?
What happened?
It's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Just practice.
It's foreplay.
It's foreplay?
Oh no!
I keep stopping!
Wait, what's going on?
What's going on?
Your synergy is going away!
Listen, listen, listen, listen.
Sometimes when lots of people are watching, it's harder, okay?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The performance anxiety.
Oh!
It's a clip!
What?
Nothing.
Hey, Sophie, welcome back.
I just sat down.
What the fuck?
You woke up.
We're making Honda Voyeur.
Whoa!
We're like friends!
We're making content!
Which site are we uploading to?
Don't...
Don't worry.
You'll find out soon.
We have 76% film left.
He is a professional.
Hey, I hope it's that map that I died on so we can get back the other camera.
We need our other camera.
It's a merge.
It's called Submerging.
It's just Submerging.
What'd you call it?
Whoa!
Oh no, it's another map!
No!
No, this is the lower floor on the same map, I think.
Oh, on the same map.
Last map?
Yeah.
Oh.
This is where we got stuck.
This flashlight's weird.
It illuminates really far away and not so much up close.
That's weird.
Oh yeah, you've got like a very nice cone shape.
It's like I turned up the field of view really fucking high.
Don't worry.
I got my hug ready.
Is that your hole?
Is that our hole?
Oh yeah, this is your hole!
That's where we died!
We found your hole.
It was made for me.
It was made for us.
This was the hole.
Okay, how I figured out to go upstairs is we have to go down.
And then...
What's that?
What's that over there?
Do you see that?
It's the ship.
Oh.
It looks like it has 20 eyes!
Oh my god!
I can't believe it!
A ship!
Oh my god, what the fuck?
I lagged out here.
Oh yeah, if you go down you can go up.
Oh, this is where I threw myself down when I was being chased by a spider.
Oh wait, this was not the same down I found.
There should be monsters down here.
You can get up from here.
What's that?
That's a monster.
It's a hole.
That's like the...
You should put your face on the pounder, Snuffy.
Yeah, you won't get pounded.
Touch the pounder.
There you go.
Are you getting healed?
Oh, thank you!
Thank you!
That was good.
Don't worry.
Oh, nice.
Thank you.
Are you full HP?
I was working.
What about this?
Will this grind my bones too?
No?
No, it won't.
You should touch it.
Okay.
Are you not going to test the theory?
I got to do it for the...
You're not going to get myth busted?
What's the myth?
The myth is that will it grind your bones?
Will it?
I tried!
I'm alone!
What the... Are you losing HP for that?
Wait, what about this thing?
Did you...
No!
I'm like immune to it!
Wait, you are?
Oh my god, you are!
Wait!
Oh my god, myth busted!
Yeah, I'm okay!
Myth busted!
You're getting like, faintly!
Are you guys just getting pounded or something?
No, no, we're busting myths right now.
We're trying to fight that.
We're busting myths!
We're both thinking grind it up.
Yeah, yeah, we want to know if we can survive it, if we're invincible.
There's a monster back here, by the way.
Oh yeah, did you film it?
Where is it?
Uh, it disappeared because I shined light on it.
Oh, is it what...
It's just the dick pistons again.
It's this way.
What?
All right.
Did any of us get touched by that monster for content?
No, it's the one that ate your ass on the first map.
Oh, that guy!
Oh, that him!
Okay, okay, okay.
All right, I'm going to get shanked by him.
Oh no, it's the tommy!
Hello, today I'm going to show...
It's the tommy!
Welcome to London!
World star!
No, no, no, stop it!
No, no, stop it!
No!
We gotta get out of here.
Okay, so, yeah.
Oh my god, it's...
Oh my god, I'm here.
I'll hug you!
I'll hug you.
Here you go.
Are you...
Oh shit!
Who's gonna hug me?
World star!
Oh my god, he's right behind us.
Ay ay ay ay.
I'm gonna hug you for a co- I'm gonna hug you- don't worry, I'm hugging you through the- through the pain!
Are you still getting sad?
Uh oh, uh oh, uh oh.
Don't worry, I can hug you through the sad things!
Oh!
Who's gonna hug me?!
Fuck!
Hug!
Hug me!
I'm one inch me!
I'M ONE INCH ME!
What's up?
Um, are they dead?
Should we leave?
No!
Grab the hugs!
Are they dead?
Should we leave?
No!
One's dead.
Who's gonna hug me?
I'm never gonna be the hugger again.
The hugger never gets hugged.
Hello?
The hugger never gets hugged!
What's the point?
Did you die?
I died.
I died for the content.
Hello?
I died for the content, for the extra views.
The hugging arc is over.
No longer will I provide comfort for people with trauma.
I'll never give- I'll never have physical touch for people with trauma.
I'll never touch ever again.
I'll be a bubble child.
I'll be in my little bubble.
No touchy.
I am the sole survivor.
This expedition.
If you see this footage, make sure to like and subscribe.
There has to be more people still alive!
No one else is in that voice!
Where are the others?
I don't know where the camera is.
I think he died.
We might have to go back there.
Do they know Han lived?
He lived.
Wait they're here!
They're here!
They're alive!
They're alive?
You're in the ship already.
How the fuck does she know?
Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
Just get to the ship.
I saw the guy here.
The stabby guy though.
He was around the corner.
How did you know?
Hey what's up?
Hey never mind.
Ahhhh!
We need to leave this.
I can't stop!
Okay I'm taking over this.
This is the game.
Guys!
Bro!
Snuffy!
I
didn't think they got it on the video!
I was spectating you!
Dude she fell!
She fucking slipped and fell.
Oh my god.
That was really humbling.
We got the content.
We got it.
We also don't...
I am not the hugger anymore.
I refuse to hug anymore.
No one ever hugs the hugger.
Emotional damage.
What the hell is this?
We are practicing for a big debut.
That apple looks tasty.
Touch the smell...
Touch the pounder.
There is the scary guy that disappears and reappears.
Oh, that... oh no!
That's the shaker!
It's the top, Eric!
World star!
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
This guy's a freak.
Wait, where did he come from?
It's a monster mash.
That was another one.
That was so... you had like three monsters on you.
I didn't realize the other guy was there.
This is the survivor.
This is Expedition.
If you see this footage, make sure to like and subscribe.
Who knows what will happen.
Just cut off before Snuffy died.
No.
I think I ran out of footage there.
The moment she slipped, it was never caught on tape.
I think the beginning was worth it.
The beginning...
That's okay.
That means we can like use our third tape for the next one.
Because we hit our quota.
We can save the next footage.
Min-max.
Min-maxing time.
So we need to like take a day off?
No, we can like film it and then we get the footage for the next day.
Yum, yum, yum, yum.
I hope this game gets updated and not left to die like Palworld.
That's all I want.
I hope this game gets freaking content.
Alright.
Someone buy the hug.
Because like I'm not the hugger anymore.
I wish for it.
Or we could go for water.
We can either hug or I can do a backflip.
It's up to you.
You know what?
I think the...
I think the backflip would be so fucking cool though.
Imagine the content.
Especially if it's for content.
This is like a free game.
This is dedicated for content.
So we should definitely just buy that thing.
I'm sure you'll do it perfectly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Me too.
I'm sure it'll be...
I'm sure that $400 would be worth it.
Alright, I'm gonna...
We still afford the hug.
What?
We still afford it.
Alright.
Show us the backflip.
How do I do it?
It's T.
Press T.
Wait.
Oh.
I landed really close to the ground.
I didn't know what happened there.
You know, for a first try, that's pretty good, you know?
The first try.
I think I'm good.
I'll figure...
I have no idea what I'm doing.
I think I'm doing it.
I've never seen a backflip.
I just read it in a book.
Anybody wanna be the hugger?
No.
That was...
That was not me.
I can do both.
No.
I'm gonna be the in-flip.
Oh my god.
You try it.
Try it.
Oh my god.
The perfect hug.
Alright.
I'm getting submerging now.
We're submerging.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh, we're back here.
I knew I would.
This was worth the money.
Yeah.
The $300.
Oh, yeah.
Dude.
Did you guys know you can lead the monster to fall to its death?
Just try and do that and get a clip.
You find a monster and then lead him to the ship and then watch him...
Oh!
And then...
Sorry.
Watch him die.
Monster.
Alright.
I'm heading up.
I'm going up.
One small step for mankind.
Alright.
Hello monster.
Monster.
Monster, I have no flashlight.
I have no idea where I'm going.
Oh, monster.
Monster.
Oh, I found a rib cage.
Rib cage.
Look at this.
This is what's gonna happen to you if you don't like this.
If you don't like this, then like and subscribe to our channel.
Nice.
Okay.
Where is Lyman?
Oh my god!
There's another rib cage!
Double rib cage.
Those are the two people that didn't like and subscribe.
That's what happens when you don't click the bell button.
Yeah.
This is what happens when you don't click it.
Just remember...
Wait.
Where are we going?
Are you guys parkouring?
I don't know.
I think we should split around in a circle.
Why don't you guys just...
I don't know.
Oh, wait.
This is how I got lost.
Yeah.
Let's go back to where we were.
Wait.
No.
We went down, didn't we?
We went up, didn't we?
Yeah.
There's no ship on the way.
We went up and if we go down, we go back to the ship.
Oh, yeah.
This is where we...
Yeah.
We have to go this way.
I forgot which way I went.
Things are blurring together.
I'm surprised we haven't seen a creature.
Me too.
A creature!
Hopefully we don't jinx ourselves.
We wanna...
We wanna use you for comfort.
A content creature.
I miss my sound more already.
Content creature.
Come here.
What are you doing?
Let us...
Oh, you mean the one that we had in game?
Yeah.
Let us manipulate you into being a content slave.
Oh.
Wait.
I hear...
I hear London!
There's something behind us.
It's giggling.
It's the London kid!
London?
Oh my god.
Where is he?
Where is the audio coming from?
He might be in our videos.
He's a fan.
I think he is above us.
Yeah.
He's stream sniping.
We're doing IRL and he's trying to stream snipe us.
Let's go investigate.
I think you guys will be seeing him very soon.
Oh my god.
Guys, he just wants to be on our stream.
He watches our channel.
Oh, here he is!
Oh, is that him?
Oh!
Shit!
Who did he shake?
Oh my god!
He's shaking!
In the corner!
He knows where the cameraman is!
Oh, he's shaking!
He wants all the screen time.
Oh my god.
Who has the hug?
Backflip and hug him!
Who's the hug him?
Yeah, he's supposed to hug him!
Oh my god.
Where?
You got it?
Oh!
There's two!
There's two stream snipers!
Oh my god.
They can jump up.
They can?
No, they can't.
Yes, they can!
I've seen it!
No, no, no, no!
Come on, we're gonna hug you!
Help!
Wait, where's our cameraman?
Oh, he's in the corner.
Guys?
Jesus Christ!
I've got the camera!
Wait, is he dead?
Yeah, he did.
Oh, he's dead.
He definitely died.
He...he...he hella dead!
Thank you for the cuddling.
Yeah, ...dead.
Oh fuck!
He got...he got stream sniped man!
Well, I'm loaded.
Oh God!
What are you guys doing?
Here, um...somebody hold me.
Okay, don't worry.
Somebody hug you?
Okay, where is it?
Where is it?
It's right here.
Oh, it's here, okay.
It's right where I got you.
Okay.
Let me know when you feel okay now.
Let me know.
I got 28% film loss.
That's enough.
Let me know when you feel okay.
Let me know.
Don't worry, I'm here for you.
Okay.
We got... I feel like let's start slowly head back to our ship because you have 28, right?
Yeah.
You can maybe get something on the way.
Yeah, might as well just head back.
Turtle guy went back.
He went up the stairs.
Yeah, don't worry.
He realized there's no more... Oh, no.
They both went to the ramp, I think.
Yeah.
There's no more screen time for that guy.
Guys, I feel like not having a flashlight was not a great idea.
I have one, but I also have the camera.
Does someone want the camera?
Oh, wait.
I can hold the flashlight.
Is this our expensive one?
It's a skedaddler!
Skedaddler?
Around the corner.
Oh, my God.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, back up, back up!
Sick, though?
It's so sick!
Oh, my God, you're going off!
Sophie, no!
Okay, we have to get out before she hits the bottom because if she hits the bottom, she crashes the game.
What?
I had a friend fall off, and she was, like, running faster and faster and further away because I was watching her progress on the ship.
And then when she got a certain distance away, the game just crashed.
Oh, shit!
That's a flammable!
I'm okay!
I'm running!
Are you still okay?
Guys, I don't think she's so okay anymore.
Guys, I don't think she's still okay.
Guys?
Where the fuck is the camera?
Oh, my God, the camera's right there!
No!
Guys, if I get picked up, I die!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
We're so close!
I got... he picked me up!
No!
The captain!
It was a really good try.
Do you think we can find that?
It should be like right there, right?
No, this is the last... I like how...
No!
We keep losing our camera on the last day.
I was like, are you okay?
And you're like, I think I'm okay.
And then I'm like, where did she go?
Yeah, he just immediately grabbed me again and tossed me around.
It was like impossible to get away.
Oh my god.
Did I fall off the cliff with the turtle?
Yeah, you did!
We did!
Did we watch you fall off?
Oh my god.
You're like, I'm okay!
I'm okay!
And then we watch you slowly fall off the cliff.
It's on the building!
Oh my god, it's okay.
We can get a hundred and... we don't need those extra... oh my god, are you okay?
We don't need those extra 128!
I flipped!
Wait a sec!
This was so worth it.
Another day of content.
The grind never stops guys.
I'm feeling good about today.
We lost a couple days, but I'm excited.
I think I feel so good too.
Don't worry guys.
I have the camera.
We don't even need flashlights.
Whatever.
We're doing our backflip, it's good content.
It's extra content.
Yeah.
That was fucking sick, man.
I wish you guys saw it.
I like your popper.
Are we good?
I feel like one of those kids that just learned how to flip in school and they just keep doing it.
Yeah, but I don't think you learned it yet after 20 years of backflip.
Alright, we're ready.
Are you ready guys?
I'm so freaking ready.
Oh hey, it's the first map.
Wait, can we find our other camera?
I landed it that time.
No, it might despawn at the end of a section.
Oh, it despawns after the end of the...
I would think so, but it would be nice to be wrong.
Chat, it's time for you guys to backseat.
Does it despawn after?
For all the content creators out there who are trying to make content.
Does it despawn?
Guys, any backseaters in Snuffy's channel, you're welcome here.
Come back to my channel.
Backseaters are allowed.
Backseaters come to my channel, Doki Bird!
Alright.
Let's see.
Wait, what?
What is that sound?
Oh my god!
Oh my god, right now!
Hey, where did he go?
I'm scared.
I don't know where he went.
He flipped off.
Oh, he fell over.
He fell over.
Oh, he's over there!
He's over there!
I see him!
He's running.
Watch me do a backflip.
Yay!
Alright, nice.
I think we're okay.
Alright, where do we go now?
He's coming back.
He's leaving.
We don't have any hugs.
We're broke right now.
Nope.
He's coming back.
We're like one of those channels that's wasted all their money.
Fight me.
For one thing.
That's right, buddy.
Motto, motto.
Fist to fist.
Oh my god, guys.
There's a fight that's about to happen.
Guys, I'm 1 HP!
I'm 1 HP.
I got hit.
Wait, there's a spider right there.
There's a spider too?
Oh my god.
Today's not a good day, guys.
Today's not a good day!
Hey guys.
There's a spider by the way.
Yeah, I can see.
Did Han die again?
Did Han wait someone else to get him?
I'm pretty sure.
I kinda do want that though.
We could check the ship.
There's something up there.
There's something at the exit.
Guys, wouldn't it be funny if there's something in front?
Holy crap.
Holy shit!
Oh shit!
You should have destroyed it.
I got fucking slapped.
What the fuck is that?
Did you guys get the camera?
Did she get the camera?
No, it's right there on the stairs.
Oh no.
Oh no!
Oh my god!
Holy moly.
That hurts so fucking bad.
Oh my god.
It's fucking...
James, stop it.
Oh my god.
I ran out of sprints so I couldn't get away.
Holy shit.
I like how Snuffy ran backwards instead of forward.
You guys could have split up and one of you made it to the ship.
Oh, it's right in front of her.
It's right in front of her.
I don't know if she can outrun it.
There's a spider too.
Can she outrun it?
Holy shit.
He's so fast.
He's so fucking smart.
You smart asses.
The gamers!
What the fuck is this?
No!
It's okay.
We can grab the camera back.
We can grab it back.
I don't know what to do.
Oh my god.
What's going on?
Why are they all trying to...
The giant was so fucking fast.
I ran out of stamina and couldn't get away.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I didn't know what to do.
I didn't think I could outrun either of them.
That was so scary.
That was so fucked up.
It was so...
Don't tell me, but that was like way different.
The other ones are like silly and that thing like...
Yeah, that thing was...
That thing two shot me.
Bro...
It fell after I...
I was already 1 HP.
And killed her instantly and it almost fell down the stairs and then it just stared at me.
Bro,
there was no way I was gonna survive.
I didn't know how to live through that.
I knew I was fucked.
I knew.
You guys were like, there's somebody in front of you.
I was like, I knew it was over.
It was so over.
It's okay.
We're on day one so we can grab our stuff back.
Oh, I hope so.
I really hope so.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna go find the other camera.
All right.
We have nothing to buy because we're broke as fuck.
Let's go.
I just look at all.
We're broke this time.
Don't worry.
This is the best thing.
Goodbye.
Click quick.
Press the button.
All right.
I knew.
Don't worry.
I'll find the camera.
All right.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll find the camera.
Wait, is this new?
No.
Okay.
The camera should be somewhere around here.
There it is.
What is it?
Should I just take it back to the ship?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I think you should...
How much film do you have left?
51%.
Oh, shit.
We have so much film.
The camera's broken though.
Oh.
No, it's broken.
I'll take it back.
Yeah, yeah.
Just throw it in the thing.
Can we still get the CD though?
Yeah, yeah.
We can get the CD.
We just can't film with it because we got slapped so fucking hard.
I heard the slapper gives like a lot of content.
I heard that every single time it slaps, it hits the like button.
Goodbye.
Welcome back.
I'm here.
Wait, where's Snuffy?
Snuffy might have ordered on us.
Oh, whoa, whoa!
Like, where the fuck did she go?
That was just perusing.
We gotta find the slapper.
He gives like a lot of views.
What's that word called when you use somebody for content without their consent?
Oh no, what's that?
What happened?
What is that?
Oh, it's a...
I'm dead.
It's okay, it's okay.
Just run around.
Oh yeah, we're gonna exploit these monsters.
Did you exploit these monsters?
You exploit the monster?
It's so dark, I don't know if my camera can see him.
Oh no.
What about the content?
Oh, she dead?
Oh, she's dead.
Oh wait, did you film?
Wait, what's that?
Yeah, I got it.
You got it?
Okay, go back to the ship!
Go back to the ship!
Oh shit!
Okay.
Where's the ship?
Are you good?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm good.
I'm walking up, I'm walking up.
I don't know if Han is alive.
We only have 80% recorded.
Okay, but if you just keep recording that one monster, I think we can...
I don't want to be able to get a lot of views, right?
Maybe there's something up here?
Oh, that's true.
Wait, where is the... Oh, the ship is over there.
Is Han dead?
I'm gonna check the ship.
Okay.
All right, let me check if he's dead dead.
I can't believe we saw that.
The first thing we saw.
All right, let's see if he's moving.
Oh, he's moving!
He's alive!
Okay, I'm gonna bait a monster near you.
All right.
Han!
Oh, hey!
You're alive!
Okay, nice.
Only Lime died.
I feel like we might be able to...
We might be able to find monsters outside.
I feel like we could...
It sounds scary outside.
We can't like, juke them.
Oh, we'll be fine.
We'll be fine.
Still, they want to call like, Ha-caw!
Yeah, apparently they like, hear our voices too.
Monster?
The fitness gram pacer test is a multi-stage aerobic capacity test.
Black and yellow, black and yellow.
Oh, there's another door here.
Maybe I'll find another monster from here.
I need my stamina though.
Monster!
We're here to exploit you for views.
For content.
Monster.
Monster?
What's that?
Did you hear that?
Okay.
Okay, welcome!
Welcome to death.
I really hope they remember to pick up the camera when we leave...
...because I'm not sure if it will...
...if it'll come with us...
...if it just sits in the thing.
Oh, yeah.
I was like...
I was going to say, did you get that?
And then I done.
I don't know how to deal with that monster.
Once it gets you, it just chain throws you and you fucking die.
It's like make another person aggro it before it picks you up again.
I guess the aggro it.
Gotcha.
Oh god, they have to go home.
Just go home.
We got the content.
How do you not have more content?
How about we go in?
Stay over here?
Oh, he's gonna be a bait.
He's gonna do it.
No!
Snuffy, what are you doing?
Why are you still walking following him?
You good?
Talented, lucky.
I think they're gonna die, Lymu.
They're so fucked.
How much...
Hello, monsters!
I'm here.
I have come to vanquish you!
Everything in this game just becomes really fucking lethal, so I...
Show thyself.
Thyself?
Themself?
Thyself, yeah.
Thyself!
I trust the vision.
It's too dark and we can't find you.
I trust it.
We can do it.
There's no way...
I just realized there's... Oh, it's a little snail.
Oh, the spookiest of monsters!
A snail!
What are you doing, Mr. Snail?
Oh!
So spooky.
We still have 30%, but maybe we'll catch something on the way out.
He's a natural content creator.
Very much so.
We're pretty...
Big guys there.
I feel like we have good odds to re-encounter something.
I don't know.
They're so dead.
There's no way.
I don't think they're gonna make it to the ship.
We've always got, like, fucked at the last possible second.
Hello.
Go up!
What are you guys doing?
You're monsters.
You're oxygen!
Mr. Conta?
Oh.
How much oxygen do they have left?
Look at their back in the canister.
It's on the right.
Oh, shit!
Yeah.
That's not a lot.
That's why I was like, why are they... why are they still exploring?
That only happens if you don't die.
Oh!
Yes, Han?
Uh...
Han?
What was that?
That only happens if you don't die.
All our entire life relies on Snuffy now.
She doesn't know where to go!
Oh, she does.
Okay.
I thought it couldn't smother her bones.
We literally myth busted that.
Oh, no.
No!
Not the end.
The monster's gonna grab her at the very end.
Oh, no.
We needed you, Han.
You have to bait.
Oh, she's so close to the ship, though.
Oh, there it is!
Don't...
Fucking...
I can't even...
Oh,
my God.
My God.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Wow.
Now that's two cameras.
Do we have to...
We did not get that back.
Wait.
We put the camera in the spaceship.
Maybe it came back with it.
Is it still there?
Oh, we put the first...
We did it again.
We just got to find the...
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
It's back.
Okay.
We got the sword.
Blessed camera.
Oh, my God.
At least we can afford flashlights now.
We still have content.
We have.
That means we can go back.
That one was good content.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We gotta go back for it.
We gotta find the camera.
All right.
I have the sword.
CD, let's go.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Is this the one where I recorded it?
It's gonna be so good.
I don't even remember what happened.
This feels like a week ago.
That was fucking sick, man.
I wish you guys saw it.
Backseat is coming to my channel.
This is great.
Oh, my God.
What is that?
It's the...
Oh, it's the...
Oh, my God.
I'm seeing right now.
Guys, you're such a...
That's a lot of...
Oh,
my God.
Guys, you're such a...
Oh, my God.
Oh, my
God.
Guys, you're such a...
Actually too many people came in the story.
What can we say?
Haha!
Hahaha!
Oh, my God!
How did you get 65k from that?
Because I got body slashed?
It was like a selfie.
The entire time.
They were like, we love this.
Like how did this come to it!
Haha.
That was fucking good.
I want to see that one again.
Haha.
That was so good.
Ha!
Alright.
Here you go.
Time to sleep.
I'm gonna stay up all night watching this.
I can't believe...
I can't believe this.
That was like the most views we've ever had.
Too.
I forgot about the whisk guy.
That feels like so long ago.
Alright.
Sleep time.
Yay!
Oh my god.
Apparently YouTube is broken right now.
I'm literally streaming this content.
It's like already on my platform.
We're doing so well guys.
I believe in us.
I mean we can...
I think we can...
I think if we get our second camera, we'll be fine.
Apparently YouTube is broken right now.
And cause I went from like...
Apparently I have like 300 people watching me cause YouTube broke.
They said less spider.
We didn't listen.
Yeah.
They're like too much spiders.
Okay.
What do we need?
What do we need to survive guys?
We need... we definitely need the hugs.
Wait, wait, wait.
We need the defib.
We need a defib.
We can afford a defib and the hugs.
Oh that'll be great.
Yeah.
Okay.
Infinite life hack.
Did we order it?
What is in our fucking bin right now?
I'm scared.
We can... oh we can afford flashlights.
I'm gonna order a flashlight for us.
We have so much money.
Is it good to just like buy a ton of shit now?
Yeah.
I mean we need it.
We really need it.
There's no reason not to I guess.
The fuck is this?
Yeah.
Infinite life hack.
Oh yeah.
I'll be the healer.
Oh you want it?
Okay.
Here you go.
Guys.
Chat.
You're all here.
Even if I have one fat...
There you go.
If Doki Bird has one fat, I'm one of them.
If Doki Bird has zero fat, it's because I'm dead.
That's you.
You guys are the chosen...
all 200 of you.
I thought I did.
Check out.
The boom mic is so weird.
It blows out the audio even more.
It's really funny.
Oh shit.
Did you guys got the flashlight, defib, and the...
I got the flashlight.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh we don't have any money.
That's real.
Yeah.
Nice.
Alright.
Here we go.
Let's go.
We're broke now.
We gotta find the camera.
Alright.
Does anyone...
The camera has to be like...
almost close to us.
I'm gonna go find the camera.
It should be.
It's near the other entrance.
I'll try to find the camera.
Don't worry.
Let's split up, gang.
That's why I learned how Scooby Doo.
Split up and find more clues.
Yeah.
What we learn in Scooby Doo is Scooby Doo can do...
Oh I found it!
Oh wait.
No.
That's...
Wait.
Is that you?
Do you find the camera?
It's gotta be around there.
Yeah.
It should be around here.
That's where she got slapped.
Right?
Where the fuck is her camera?
It's right here.
Oh.
Okay.
I grab it.
There it is.
It's underneath the bones here.
Alright.
I'll grab it.
I can take it back.
Okay.
You're gonna take it?
Yeah.
I'll take it back.
Alright.
Oh.
Does someone want the flashlight?
Yeah.
I can take it.
We have 85%.
Alright.
Let's put the camera.
Let's...
Make sure she... Let's escort her.
Give a buddy system.
And make sure she makes it to the ship.
Make sure she makes it to the ship.
Let's make sure she doesn't die while we walk back.
And get slapped.
It doesn't look like there's anything.
That's nice.
Wait.
Snuffy.
Did you... Did you get footage of the slapper?
Wait.
Snuffy.
Did you...
Did you get footage of the slapper?
I think I did.
I did.
Okay.
Good.
I hear he's like a lot of views.
Okay.
Good.
I hear he's like a lot of views.
Yeah.
Oh.
Really?
Yeah.
That's like a combination of like the... Both the times we died.
Okay.
There we go.
Alright.
Nice.
I was like if I'm dying, it's for the content.
You know?
Exactly.
It's all about going vital.
For the content.
If you don't die for your content, then what's the point?
Do not follow...
Do not listen to me.
That's not really good advice.
Where?
It's a fucking Tonberry again.
Oh my god.
He's a fucking stream sniper.
Alright.
We'll give it to Milken.
Yeah.
Give him some of that content.
Oh, they're shy.
Yeah.
He wants to be a famous stream sniper.
You can become famous that way, guys.
Then like...
Oh my gosh.
There's like so many big streamers that became famous just for stream sniping.
But also don't stream snipe us, guys.
You won't get famous from stream sniping VTubers.
It only works for IRL content.
Here we go.
Content time.
Where are you?
You don't know that.
It could be...
Oh.
It is a dead end.
Guys, it is a dead end.
Oh, it's a dead end.
Wow.
Look at that.
Who would have thought?
Guys, why didn't you tell me it was a dead end?
Guys.
I'm sorry we haven't found the lasers yet.
We could have done some limbo.
I think we go this way.
Oh my god.
Apparently YouTube is broken that people can't chat right now.
But they can super chat.
Oh my god.
You gotta pay to chat.
It's pay to win.
Pay to chat.
If you want to communicate with a streamer you gotta have the money.
That's so fucked up.
Wait, there's a spine.
The big ribbon?
Did you guys hear me?
Did you film the spine?
Oh shit.
Someone quick hug him.
He's got the hugs.
Wait, you have the hugs?
I've got you.
Thanks.
Alright, film the hugs.
Light him up!
Put the light on him!
Thank you.
Jesus Christ.
Guys, I'm stuck.
Can I have a hug?
Guys.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Who has the hugs?
He's back!
I flashed him.
I don't think he likes it.
Who has that?
He doesn't like the light.
I would like a hug.
Thank you.
There we go.
He doesn't like light.
Don't worry.
Get the light!
I got it!
Wait, we have the camera.
Yeah, we don't have the flashlight.
Alright, I have the defib too.
How much more film do we have left?
We only have 20%.
I think that's enough.
We should head back.
There's gonna be a fucking time.
There's a giant up there anyway.
Yeah, I feel like we're gonna get fucked over again.
Wait, where's this way?
Oh, they ran off the road.
Oh, wait.
We're good.
Yeah, don't worry.
I'm never lost.
No, of course not.
Don't worry.
I got this.
Guys, don't worry.
I will go further.
I am very brave.
I'm almost out of oxygen.
Did he squeeze the oxygen out of my ass or something?
I think he did.
No, we're the same.
Did he squeeze the...
He was trying to fucking perform CPR but fucked up.
There's something over there on the right hand side.
I don't know what it is.
Where is that?
It's underneath all that crap over there.
Chris?
Where?
Where is it?
Is it the stream sniper again?
Stream sniper?
Where is it?
Did you lie, lie, mo...
It's the shaker!
It's the stream sniper.
Oh shit!
It's the stream sniper!
Okay, okay.
I'm okay.
I dropped my flashlight.
We don't need it.
It was a cheap one.
Don't worry.
It's okay.
Guys?
Oh my camera!
Where's the camera?
Let's go!
We live!
We finally arrived!
Okay We have to figure out if the this first camera Or the second the first camera would give us the views or not, or should we just commit to the last one?
Um, the first one might have giant footage we could do that.
All right.
Okay.
We'll do the first then All right.
Okay, and then we'll save the other one.
We still need to make a CD out of it.
I grabbed it.
Is this the first one?
That's the broken one.
The broken one?
Okay.
Wait do an emo.
That's good.
That's all we need All right, I got the film.
Do we get double movie night?
Yeah.
No, no We save the other one and we don't make enough views we can use it.
But for now we'll do this one first
Did you back flip?
What is that snake mech I'm gonna check the ship.
Okay I feel like... the hero returns.
Did you hear that?
Someone just said ha ha ha like malicious in response to me fucking dying.
What a dick
You fuckery tea baggy
She found out
Bye self.
Yeah Bye self The spookiest of monsters A snail How do you use the snake?
Is that a snail?
Just heard a scary noise might die
Where the fuck is the slapper?
It's just like one second of the slapper Just heard a scary noise might die I'm so sorry Yeah, we gotta save the other CD That was plenty of views.
Did you guys get the other one?
Yeah, but we gotta save it for next time We finally are able to save the CD We can hold on to it right?
Where is the other CD?
Does it have it?
No Who has it?
I don't have it.
What happened?
If we sleep, it'll respawn Oh no, it's in the tray.
It's in the tray It's right over here Yeah, okay.
We don't have to worry.
We can just sleep now Okay Alright, we'll be fine Don't worry
That's all that matters
Alright Three days left Good morning everybody Are you guys ready for more content?
Yeah We need 3...
We need 325k views now Jesus That's a lot That's a lot of views Guys, it's been over money Wait, what?
What?
What did you spy?
Is that...
Anybody like this?
Is that the ancient gesture?
Is that the...
Is this the gesture I think it is?
Oh yeah, yeah it is Is it?
I think you deserve it Okay, I deserve it.
Oh it is!
Oh my god, we have one dollar left!
But it was fucking worth it Hahaha Hahaha Wonderful Yeah, okay, wait, wait, wait, are you ready?
Wait, wait, wait, we got the green screen.
Let's green screen this Wait, wait, someone come to the...
Where's the green screen?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, here
Okay On the moon It's like I'm on the moon, guys Hahaha Oh my god She's back flipping on the moon!
Oh my god!
No gravity, dude!
Bro, fucking... Oh my god, this is sick, dude!
No shit!
We can flip off the dolphins.
Oh, here we go!
Yeah!
Hahaha Okay This is gonna actually film the monsters Hahaha World tour!
We're gonna have a compelling...
Cool in.
Okay We got a big result.
We gotta make them wait till the very end That's like our channel intro That's...
We gotta get some big font on top of that Yeah!
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Don't mind what that is Alright, here, I'm ready Oh, this flashlight's great Look how much light I get here I got the defib Nice So like, if we die, I have defib really This is the best flashlight Nice.
Oh wait, is this a hole that we can jump in?
Oh my god!
Okay, who has the camera?
I do Alright, watch this Oh wait, no, not yet, not yet I fucked it up.
Okay, watch this Watch this God damn it!
Okay, give me a sec I can do this.
Alright No!
I almost...
Okay, one more time!
One more time!
What the fuck?
I'm floating!
I...
It was worth it It was worth it, guys Ow I used like 25% of film today It was worth it!
We could get so much content!
Woah, did you guys hear that?
Oh no, it was the door Can we go back up though?
We gotta find...
Down is up See, look, down is up I told you!
Look!
There's a thing here It's up here this way Can we not go up here?
Where does this go?
Wait, I feel like... Let's split up, gang Wait, who has the camera?
What's the point of splitting up?
What's the point of this?
You don't know that!
We could like find her...
Find them in another area Wait, where did you guys go?
Hello?
Hello guys?
Guys!
I can hear you say keep moving forward!
Really?
Hello?
Guys, don't worry AHHHHH Oh my god, who shot?
Guys, guys Who was that?
Guys, are you guys okay?
Oh my god, it's a slapper!
Did you get the content?
Run, run, run, run, run!
Oh my god Oh my god
Oh my god Oh my god The camera is over there!
There is a snail too!
Ohhhhh Run, run, run, run, run!
Run, run, run, run, run!
LIE!
You are lying!
She is coming back to life!
Did she AFK when I revived her?
I think she...
Oh, jeez!
What?
Maybe she will pick it up, maybe she will realize Did she fucking...
Oh my god!
Do you understand me, Emoji?
I like how she was like, what?
Motherfucker!
What the fuck?
Wow!
Did you AFK?
You have the magnets in your head.
What the hell?
Did he just teleport onto me?
He literally like...
He ran straight at you!
Bro!
Bro, did you like AFK?
Did you AFK when I revived you?
I had to...
I was like, okay, I'm dead So I tabbed and went to go deal with my dog And then suddenly like, I was alive!
I was like, run, run, run, Emo!
And then I died and I just see you standing there AFK!
I was so sorry!
I was like, okay, I'm dead, perfect time to go take care of some chores!
Nope!
And then I came back and was like, wait, how am I alive?
I'm so sorry!
Oh my god!
About to revisit my grave...
The other guy found me.
He fucking teleports, I swear to god.
He got back and gets slapped.
It doesn't look like there's anything.
It's gonna be the first guy we see.
It's not rare.
It's the fucking Tonbury again!
Oh my god!
He's a fucking stream sniper.
Alright, well get to milking.
Get to milking?
For the content.
Milking him for the content.
Yes!
Oh, there he is!
He doesn't know where to go.
He's so angry.
Light him up!
Put the light on him!
Thank you!
Oh, he's back!
Okay.
Get the light!
Look at our views though.
Look at it go up.
Oh my god!
165?
Did we find a slapper here?
No we didn't.
We found like the regular guys.
Yay!
As long as we find our other camera, we can get a lot of views.
Because we filmed the slapper.
Is this the first one?
Holy shit!
Oh my god, thank god!
We have money!
We're broke!
We don't have anything again!
Oh my god!
We're always broke!
That's our secret!
We live to survive.
Good morning!
Mr. Beast, I locked my friends into a 1000 deep tunnel.
For seven days.
You forgot to add for seven days.
For seven days!
I'm being stranded on ancient technology planet.
We need a flashlight, a hug, and a deep pip.
Do we have enough?
I'll put the hug.
Holy shit, that's a $500 flashlight?
Imagine how bright it could be.
Okay, we have $400 left.
Should we spend it on the long flashlight?
I like the modern flashlight better.
Okay.
We'll buy two then.
Hell yeah.
Wait, I don't think we have enough.
Yeah, we don't.
We don't have enough.
I couldn't math.
I couldn't math!
Why would you rely on me on mathematics, Han?
You know I can't do math!
Alright.
I got the modern flashlight.
I should...
Wait, I'll be a deep fib.
I'll be a deep fib.
Let me know if anybody wants the camera.
Alright, I'm ready.
No, I don't like the flashlight.
Yeah, the pressure is way too much.
Are you guys ready?
We gotta find the camera.
Does anyone remember where it was?
Does anyone remember?
Wait, what?
We died?
I don't remember much of anything.
Oh.
Wait, I don't know how to do this.
I don't know...
What do you mean goop?
Oh, the goop's here already?
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, we baited to its death.
He's gonna fall off.
Cause he doesn't know what to do.
He's gonna fall off, right?
He doesn't look like he's falling off.
Film him!
Free content!
What happens if I...
Oh, no!
This is funny!
Guys, we have to hurry!
Get caught!
Get the camera before he...
Oh, there's a monster!
There's a monster!
Oh, shit!
Fight the dead!
Defend me, defense!
No!
You deserve that.
What did I do?
I didn't yell at him.
Thank you.
You killed me.
I opened the door.
Harmony always bites back.
That's different.
I'm back alive.
Thank you.
I didn't want to hear Han yell at me.
Here's your defense.
Oh, no.
Oh, wait!
She fell off the camera?
No!
Okay, we have...
I don't remember how hard they can call.
It's not that hard.
Okay, let's just try to find the other camera.
We just need the other camera.
Does anyone...
I don't know.
It's like a mouse.
We have to figure out how to find it.
Where the other camera is.
Where could it be?
Was it above us?
No, it would have fallen...
No, I meant like the second camera.
Oh, god.
The camera we died with.
We have to figure out how to...
It should be above us.
Right?
Oh, god.
No.
There's something in here.
Oh, no.
We don't have a camera to catch it to.
Nope.
Oh, no.
It's making flapping noises.
I'm kind of uncomfortable actually.
Me too.
It's getting closer.
Oh, god.
Limo?
I think they hit terminal velocity.
Oh.
Wait, what happened?
What happened?
When you fall for a certain amount of time, it crashes the game.
Did you crash too?
What the fuck?
Yeah, I did.
Yeah, if someone falls...
Wait, I'm still in the game.
I'm still in the game.
It just works.
Well, I think we were...
Well, actually, I don't know.
I don't think we were screwed.
That super sucks.
They haven't come back yet though.
Wait, no.
I think I gotta restart the game.
Oh, shit.
I'm still in the game.
I'm still in.
Guys, I was still in the game.
Oh, you were?
Yeah, I'm still in.
We crashed.
I wasn't even the server owner.
Wait, how was the server owner?
Han, you gotta remake the server.
Huh?
We had terminal velocity, so everything crashed.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'm disconnected.
I'm gonna wait for the invite.
I got you.
Oh my god.
I can't believe I opened the door.
You let me fall all the way down there.
I was...
I was supposed to...
I just opened the door.
Oh, I wonder what's keeping them anchored down inside the ship.
You know, maybe glitches or something.
Open the door!
Okay, you walked into him.
That was your fault for walking into the guy.
And you kicked me off the cliff.
We had a defib and everything.
We were planned for this.
It was for the content.
Yeah, we were so planned.
The defib made me...
Frickin' 100,000 meters below the surface.
You were so fast.
Wait, wait, wait!
It didn't count the day!
Ooh, result!
Wait, what does that mean?
It meant...
Okay, wait.
Snuffy's not here yet.
I was like, we left her.
Yeah, so I guess we get like a read-in.
Oh my god.
Bro, but that was such good content when Han fell down the ship.
That was such good content.
We missed out.
Alright, let's wait for Snuffy.
Snuffy, you're so fast.
You're so fast.
Where is she?
What color am I?
Am I still red?
I am.
Nice.
Oh, it resets the volume of everybody too.
I just noticed.
It resets everybody's volume.
Uh, I can't invite Snuffy for some reason.
Oh, I can invite her.
Alright.
Or Lime can.
Uh, yeah, I'll invite her.
Yeah, yeah, one of us can invite her.
How do I join?
You can join the game.
I just invited you.
It's just like, how do I get in here?
Hi Snuffy!
It reset the day so we get another chance.
We have another chance.
We don't need a backflip anymore.
Oh my god, you're right.
We lose our emotes.
Oooh.
Oh, and it wipes...
I remember it wipes the camera too.
Oh.
All my settings are different.
It wipes the camera as well.
So like, uh...
We won't be able to grab the camera from the last day.
Because we have to reset it.
We don't even think about it.
Bro, but it has to slap her though.
Wait, do we buy the defib?
You think he won't be slapping us again?
Oh yeah, that's true.
He might slap us again.
Grab the defib and the hug.
Alright.
We're so back.
Guys, I have...
Oh my god, guys, I'm blowing up.
I don't have 200 viewers anymore.
Guys.
Oh my god, I'm going viral live at this moment.
Dude.
Oh my god.
The slapper.
Did you get slapper content?
Yeah, I got the slapper.
They heard about the slapper content.
They can't...
Oh my god.
I'm going viral as we speak.
Going from a 200 Andy to a...
to a 4k Andy.
Someone grab the hug?
Come here, come here.
It's a freaking miracle.
Come here, back seating works.
Back seating works.
What?
Look.
It's our...
It's our items.
Oh, it's our ancient gestures.
I don't remember which one's mine.
Oh my god.
Yours is the peace sign.
What is this?
Nice, nice, nice.
Yeah, Han never bought an emote.
Guys, and you said you were gonna ban all back seaters.
You gotta learn to appreciate.
I've been chained.
They got me back my back flip.
You gotta unban the back seaters now.
You gotta do those streams where it's like...
We've been on our crew three times that size.
Alright, are you ready to go?
Ready for content?
Yes, dude.
Yes, content, content.
Content time.
We're so back.
What are you...
What did you order?
Did you order the goo?
I saw that.
You ordered the goo, didn't you?
You're gonna goo them, aren't you?
You can't, you can't.
You can't.
I saw it.
I saw what it was.
We're so back.
We can do this.
We can get 300.
Oh, there's no way we can die this time too.
Because there's no hole.
Yeah, there's no holes.
There's no holes.
Yeah, there's definitely no way we'll die in another way.
Wait, but then the content.
Okay.
For content though?
Yeah, for content.
I have a defense.
Guys, I have a defib.
So we die.
You're gonna be stuck up there, aren't you?
No, no, we can just chuck it.
Who wants to do it?
I'll defib.
3, 2, 1.
Who's gonna do it?
Who has the least important items?
I have a flashlight.
I'm going.
I start screaming.
Oh, god, no!
What a world!
Oh, my life!
Hey, thank you.
I did it.
You have to chuck it at them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna try again.
I'll show you a demonstration.
I'll do it again.
It'll be so funny.
Okay, but can someone hug me first?
I feel very vulnerable.
I got you.
Thank you.
Don't worry.
Trauma isn't real.
Let's do this.
Oh, god, no!
I'm so vulnerable!
I'm scared!
This is gonna take forever.
Don't worry.
I can do it.
I can replicate this.
There you go.
See?
That's how you do it.
Thank you.
A hug.
Can I have another hug, please?
I still feel like Billy, you're emotional.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot.
Let me give this back to you as well.
Thank you.
Holy!
Guys, it's my turn!
I taught you this!
I taught you, guys!
I hit you with it!
There you go.
There's a bone.
I got a bone, though.
Hey, guys.
This character steps on a shovel type moment.
If anyone grabs...
You have the defib, right?
I got bone, though.
Look at this.
Look at this sick bone.
That's right behind you, I think.
This.
Yeah, I dropped the defib.
Tomberry!
What the fuck is that?
Oh, shit!
Oh, god.
Help me!
Okay.
Wait, did he die?
Did he die?
He got shaked to death!
Don't worry.
I have the defib.
Where is he?
Oh, look.
There's goop.
There's goop right here.
Where is his body?
He's still in the thing.
Don't worry.
There's goop.
You're alive!
Tom, you're alive!
Get down from here!
Hi!
I can't chuck him down!
Oh, my god.
He's dead again!
You died again, Ron!
You should have bought an emote!
Wait, there's a slime!
Oh, god.
No, it's his slime!
He spent our money on that slime!
Guys, we have to get him down because there's a cool down for him.
Oh, shit.
The shooty robot!
The shooty robot on the grabby hook!
Do it!
Ah!
Oh, my god.
He's so doomed.
Oh, you're so fine!
No!
Did I revive you and you were just still stuck?
Were you still alive when you were dead?
Yeah.
Did I die again?
Oh, my god.
Did she get the content?
No!
I think she has to go.
I think she has to leave.
I need to go get everybody's... what?
No, just leave!
Just leave!
It's not worth it!
At least if she dies, she can just leave the camera here, maybe.
Oh, that's true!
That's true!
Oh!
See?
Giga brain.
Yeah, but the thing is, there's like three monsters outside.
I can literally hear it.
Yeah, we can literally hear them pulsating.
Yeah, they're pulsating again.
I can literally hear them going against the door right now.
Oh!
Nobody's there.
What's the worst that could happen?
She dies?
That would be so funny, though.
I like how she's looking at the ground.
Oh, no, no, no, no!
It's right there!
Oh, yeah, I don't see it.
Oh, I see it now.
I feel like we just got like ganged up.
I hope she remembers the ceiling down there.
Oh, that would be so funny if she doesn't remember.
Wait, there's two of them there.
I liked how Han inked with the goo when he got like...
Where the fuck did everybody die?
He instantly threw the fucking goo.
Oh, oh.
What is she trying to do?
I don't think she sees our bodies over there.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Her face pops out.
I'm gonna try to cover your item.
Her face properly represents what's...
Just leave.
We can buy new items.
Where did you go?
Just leave.
Guys, apparently...
Apparently, you can charge your items if you hold Q.
I just figured it out.
All on my own.
What do you mean charge them?
If you hold your Q, you can throw them higher.
Oh.
I just figured it out myself.
That explains why the apple was not like at all a satisfying food.
Oh.
Can she still use it?
Will you die?
No, I'm still dead.
I got baited.
I'm still dead.
I was dead for too long.
Where the fuck did you go?
Okay.
Whatever.
My defense.
I'm leaving.
Oh no, no.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I'm out.
Bye.
What the fuck was that?
Did you see that?
Wait.
I didn't see that.
There was something behind her.
Alright.
We're back.
Look at that, two dollars of hospital bills.
We didn't hurt too hard.
I tried to fall through the world again!
I defibbed you and you immediately started falling.
Wait, that's what happened?
Your body started falling.
I was like, I'm back!
And I was like, JK, I'm still dead.
I got baited.
Yeah, no, I went back to the ship and your body was like...
I was just not here.
Alright, we have really good content for this.
I did save this, so here you go.
Here's your defib.
Oh my god, I'll charge it.
Oh wait, it's fully charged already.
Nice.
That's good, because defib was like $300.
I couldn't find a flashlight, unfortunately.
It's alright.
Flashlights are replaceable.
Don't walk into that.
Don't walk into that?
I'm going...
The way you slowly walked there.
I started screaming.
What a world!
My life is flashing before my eyes!
Thank you.
I'm feeling brave enough now.
Alright, let's do this.
Let's do this.
Oh god, help!
I'm so vulnerable!
This is going to take forever.
Holy shit.
I'm so sorry.
I'm not.
Looks like you're shooting hoops.
I'm doing basketball.
There's Goop right here.
He's still in the thing.
There's Goop.
I was really impressed by that.
I can't get down from here!
Guys, we have to get...
Robot!
The shooting robot on the ground!
He has boots!
She wanted to get involved in basketball.
No!
You missed the part where he threw Doki directly at me and we both died.
Doki collision.
Doki collision!
They're right behind me, aren't they?
I think someone's playing sick beats.
You were right.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
We're so close.
We got to 30000 meters before I left.
That was close.
You almost crashed the server again.
Oh, my.
I forgot about...
That was so scary because you didn't fall for me.
I was so glad you fell.
Yeah.
I wouldn't even know.
I like the vibrating Han there.
On the fucking monster.
He starts vibrating.
Okay, last day for content.
We gotta make...
We can't die for this one.
Okay, we can't die.
We can't die.
Okay, I got defib.
We need the hugs and the flashlight.
I don't have anything.
What did we buy?
Blink.
Flashlight and hugs.
The jokilision.
Alright.
We got the hugs.
Are you guys ready?
Last day for content.
Last day.
We can do this.
We can get 325k viewers so easily.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
If our Oshii Logan Paul can do it, so can we.
What's our Oshii Logan Paul?
Oshii Logan Paul.
Yeah, our Oshii Logan Paul.
Bro, he's like a millionaire now.
He owns Prime.
Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime.
The Amazon?
What?
Did you just say the Amazon?
Oh my god.
It's the...
Yeah, it is.
Go back, go back, go back, go back, go back, go back.
Oh my god.
Did it hit me?
No!
Just found the contour.
Uh.
Hey, what's up?
Oh my god, hug me.
Oh my god, do you have the hug?
I don't know where the camera is.
No, I saw her.
She was behind us.
And she was behind us.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it was either Snuffy or...
We need to go get the camera.
He's camping the room, I can see him.
Okay, okay, I'll stay here.
Okay, no, no, use me as bait.
Wait, wait, wait.
No!
It's okay, we can do this.
I remind you, they took your voice.
Your beautiful voice.
We don't need to know.
We can do this by spirit.
Okay.
They don't need...
She doesn't need my voice.
Okay.
We can figure this out.
Okay, here's the plan.
That's not the plan.
I can't hear you.
If you can hear me, you keep the items, you stay here.
I'm gonna make a hero run.
Okay?
Okay.
Okay, he fucks off.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, fantastic.
Here we go.
When he leaves, Jesus Christ.
I don't think he's gonna leave.
And you know, if I die, I'll stop moving and then you can come out and res me.
It'll be great.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Bro.
Oh no.
He's camping us.
Why was I here?
Wait, can you hear someone die?
Wait, it's the shaker.
What the fuck is that?
It's the shaker, it's London.
It's London again.
Oh no.
This is our last day too.
It's not leaving.
I kinda wanna open it.
I wish we could hear you.
Shh.
Sometimes I can still hear your voice.
Don't talk.
No.
Shh.
Stop laughing.
I don't think they're going to leave.
Stop talking.
Wait.
It's going quiet.
Why does it sound like one of them is just lying?
Shut the fuck up.
I moved.
Okay.
I'm going to go for it.
Let's see.
Neither of them are further than 50 meters away.
Okay, the camera must be close.
Here we go.
I see the fucking Tom Berry.
Okay, wish me luck.
Bye, Doki.
Bye.
Fuck off, you bitch.
Do you think she's alive still?
Yeah.
Still moving.
She's still moving.
I think it's okay.
No, she's still alive.
41.
She is still alive.
She's still running.
She's running really fast right now.
I think she's getting chased.
She's...
Oh, she stopped.
Wait, no.
Oh.
No, she stopped.
Stop.
Yeah, she stopped.
She's dead.
No, she's 100% dead, guys.
She's so dead.
No!
Okay, gotta be quiet.
Oh, no, it's the shaker.
Oh, no.
No.
No, please let me get to them!
I'm trying to find the camera!
I don't even have hugs!
Oh my god.
This is the last day!
No!
She's right there!
Yeah...
No!
We failed!
We failed to gain popularity!
No!
All my dreams were growing!
My dreams!
My life was made.
I got... What happened to you, LaVuHu?
Did you get chased by the shaker?
I got chased by two of them.
Two of them were running around in circles shanking me.
Oh my god.
You think this was a good time to call it?
I got the camera but then they shanked me twice.
It was awful.
Guys, it was a great time having you guys as my content team.
Hell yeah.
I had a great time.
But I think every channel deserves to die at some point.
We gotta do that at some point.
We gotta do our own solo careers, guys.
We have to break up and do be our own.
I wanted to do Let's Plays but they didn't want to listen.
We wanted to do solo reviews.
We all gotta separate and make our own channels.
And get our own play button.
Yo, I'll die out there.
No!
You are more than just a group, Hun.
You have a personality.
I don't know how to transition out of this.
I'm gonna die.
No!
My content dried up.
You do not need to be restricted as a group collaborator.
You can do solo content too.
I'm gonna start streaming.
Don't make me start streaming.
No!
That was fun.
I had a great time.
Thank you.
You had a great time.
I'm tired.
It was so nice to meet you, Daimu.
It was wonderful meeting you.
Thank you for coming and hanging out.
Yeah.
I will never hit a million views.
This was like the same area where I died too in my last collab.
I didn't get past 300.
It's because that rapper keeps showing up and wiping us.
Bro, like, how could...
We just got there too and he just showed up.
Oh, my goodness.
He was just like, hey, I'm gonna ruin your whole career.
Yeah, we never got chance to afford a stun gun because we kept dying.
We kept wiping out.
We got so fucked up.
We got stream sniped to the point we had to get a stun gun.
We needed protection.
Guys, we should have hired a bodyguard instead of somebody that fucking hugs.
Guys.
The content is even raw.
The raw content.
People want the emotional.
They want the hugs.
They want the realness.
The realness.
Thank you guys for playing.
Yeah, thank you guys.
GG's everyone.
Thank you all for joining us too.
I'm going to sleep after this.
Oh, yeah.
You're fucking jet lagged as hell.
Nice meeting you guys.
I'll see you guys.
Have a good night.
Bye.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe it.
We died in the same place.
The same view count.
We're never going to hit a million.
We'll never hit a million.
But it was great.
I had a great time with all of them.
It was really nice to meet Limu for the first time.
Han was extremely jet lagged.
He was telling us before we started the stream that he was still suffering from jet lag because he hasn't been in NA time zones for a couple of months now.
So he was like, yeah, I should be sleeping right now.
I was like, oh, I'm sorry.
Fine.
But I had a great time.
It was really great meeting Limu and doing a collab with her for the first time.
And it was really fun.
But hey, I was snuffy again too.
Really great chemistry with snuffy.
Oh, my gosh.
That was so funny when YouTube died.
I was like, holy shit.
I was like, oh, my God, I fell off.
I knew eventually I'd fall off.
I was like, what the fuck?
Oh, my God.
I was like, bro, how did I drop from 6K to fucking 200?
And I'm like, I knew it.
It was only a matter of time when I was about to fall off.
I fucking knew it.
Even if I fall off, at least I have you dragoons.
The super dedicated ones.
But it was a great time.
I love how, like, that's so fucked up when, like, you have to pay the chat.
That was so fucked up.
I was like, people were like, we can only chat by super chatting.
I'm like, oh, my God.
That's so fucked up, bro.
That's so...
YouTube.
Darkblade, thank you for listening to the chat.
Thank you.
That was really funny.
I hope you guys had a great time.
I'm going to call it here, everybody.
My voice is dying.
So I'm going to rest up.
Tomorrow is also a rest day.
So I get to rest a double.
But, yes, I hope you guys enjoyed the collab, everybody.
As always, everyone, stay hydrated.
Pause to check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, I'll see you guys later.
Okay.
Head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.